so I'm absolutely brilliant performance
um banished line score for you no losses
in this tournament and this is your
first major tournament Victory sum up
your feelings for us right now yeah I
mean I feel absolutely amazing right now
it's it's been an insane tournament my
form just got better and better every
single day and I think today was
probably my best chest of the event And
the emotions we could see they were
rising and Rising all the way until the
last moment and you couldn't sit at the
board in that last game against Fabi
you're pacing you are trying to look
maybe at the other boards how is the
tension feeling uh in those critical
moments yeah definitely very nervous but
I was just saying look at Sam's game I
mean if he agrees to draw I would make
Perpetual right away but since he wasn't
I had to play for a win absolutely and
you did indeed have that chance at one
moment when you could have played King
to D7 King to C8 back but you weren't
sure about what's happening in Sam's
position right how did you come up to
the conclusion that you have to go for
it you have to go for the win uh well
first of all even after I take the
exchange I can always just bully his
Queen with my queen if I really want to
make a draw so I just came to the
conclusion that I just am I'm not really
risking much at all and we're talking
about this moment when you could have
repeated the position with King D7 King
C8 you did take
how far was Sam's gay very far yeah you
couldn't see it it was the other side
yeah
absolutely absolutely but let's rewind
back a little bit because yeah this was
the mode
when your attack started Queen to wave
four king to B1 and then you made a
standing move you didn't even like sit
down after King B1 he played Rook to D6
yeah tell us about your calculator oh
well he spent some time after I played
E5 and I think I'm already probably a
little better after E5 and uh while he
was thinking I saw this line with Rook
D6 and it just looked like at the very
worst I should have Perpetual in these
lines so there's no reason not to play
it absolutely and he got to this
position you sacrificed then you went
with Rook to G6 at this point I think
you had the opportunity to once again
force a repetition I I think that yes
yes like this that was a repetition you
could have taken it but you played yeah
there's one very interesting move here
Queen F2 exactly I wanted to ask and now
rookie gb6 check A1 and I think I have
to Guru K5 perfect wow
rugby 5 is losing
um so if you defend the pawn with Rook
to B5 this is losing because of D3
Rook to A5 is winning
which is uh quite crazy
just trying to understand the difference
of D3 Queen B4 uh-huh
uh Knight B3 Queen C3 uh Queen A3 oh
Queen A3 yes yes and now you can take
and there's protected right
yeah I think the Instinct of A5 just to
keep the Rook on the B file yeah because
uh Rook gg6 is very natural to play but
once you see Queen F2 it's kind of uh
scary
Sam absolutely brilliant performance I
have to say you're showing that you're
one of the best chess 9lx players on the
planet how are you going to celebrate
this Victory uh you know just really
relax and rest up and for a few days and
then get ready for the US Championship
that's a big one coming up guys during
the conversation absolutely uh Nancy all
I want to say is that huge
congratulations and you really inspired
me and I'm sure a lot of fans to start
playing chess 9lx
you play a lot of Chess during the LX uh
Sam yeah uh for fun I play online on
various websites just against good
players because it really does help with
the imagination and I think it's it's a
really fun variant uh you got a big
compliment from one of your colleagues
Sam Shanklin came on and we asked him
what his best move in the tournament was
and he said working with you uh prepping
for the games and he he actually had a
very good tournament along your side you
so again our great compliments and our
congratulations well done yeah
absolutely he you know we started
working round one and then we played in
game two but after that we were working
in every single game for the tournament
and uh like against Wesley and then he
was playing veneer like we both had this
insane line which just gave plus one to
both of us after that we just decided
we're sticking together
that was a good decision Sam first of
all uh congratulations just an
incredible performance I have to say go
get some rest go get ready for the U.S
Championship you are the 2023 chess nine
legs Champion congratulations thank you
absolutely our congratulations indeed
and there he is 37 500 richer but uh
calling yourself Champion that's uh that
feels really really really good
absolutely and what a dominating
performance I can't get over that in
this field exactly I have such a
dominated performance